[Music]
one of the things we're going to do with
this film is go around the world and
we're gonna take the audience deep into
Africa to meet some extraordinary dogs
that are saving wildlife every day and
those images are stunning
tipper and Tony these bloodhound tracker
dogs they're kind of like the world's
greatest detectives everything about
them is built to smell the way that
their ears direct the scent up into the
nostrils even the drool to bring back to
life these dried up scent molecules
[Music]
tipper and Tony and the anti-poaching
team they're basically protecting the
wildlife
so if poachers are spotted in the area
they get called in to find the poachers
by following their smell and what we're
gonna do is use the magic of visual
effects to bring the smell to life as if
you could see it
Tony Antipa as leaders into many
recoveries and arrests so we feel like
that really very good numbers of wanting
[Music]
to see them on the front line of
conservation and being not only just
super effective but to see the
communities who really didn't know
anything about dogs and embrace them and
just look at them differently and say
they help us
it's such a beautiful story about how
dogs can make the world a better place
you